important to note that the cooling of
the EU credit Market
is a sign of effective transmission of
the monetary policy normalization
rather than a sign of weakness of the EU
banking sector
thanks to reforms implemented since the
global financial crisis
indeed EU banks have solid Capital
position robust asset quality and
sufficient liquidity buffers
so in the first quarter of this year GDP
grew by 0.3 percent in the EU which is
like slightly above the projection of
our previous forecast
information available at this stage for
only a few countries pointed points to
subdued consumption growth and robust
investment growth despite the tightening
of financing conditions that I just
mentioned
net exports contributed to growth
thanks to the Improvement in terms of
Trades and a strong tourism performance
for the second quarter
survey indicators suggest continued
expansions
with Services clearly outperforming the
manufacturing sector in particular the
energy intensive manufacturing sectors
are still reeling from the energy shock
of last year
consumer confidence has continued also
its recovery from last autumns historic
low
overall growth this year
in our forecast is set to reach one
percent in the EU and 1.1 in the Euro
area so no recession but subdued growth
following the weakness in the past two
quarters private consumption is set to
increase moderately this year
as inflation keeps eroding households
purchasing power
housing investment which is of course
particularly sensitive to interest rates
is expected to contract by contrast
business investment is projected to
still increase
though at a slower Pace than last year
held by corporates overall healthy
balance sheet position and the rollout
of the RF
net exports are expected to contribute
positively to GDP but only moderately
weaker demand from Key trading partners
and the stronger Euro weigh on exports
furthermore the rebounding economic
activity expected in China
is said to benefit primarily the
domestic sectors services in particular
with limited positive spillover to the
EU in 2024
growth is expected to gain strength
moderating inflation continued employees
and expansion and strong wage growth are
projected to boost households real
disposable incomes leading to a rebound
on private consumptions
investment is expected to be supported
by the rrf despite the delayed impact of
monetary policies tightened
stronger import growth in line with
strengthening domestic demands lowers
the contribution of external demand to
growth overall annual GDP growth is
projected for 2024 at 1.7 in the EU and
1.6 in the Euro area
almost all EU economies
are expected to continue growing in 23
then experience a pickup in activity in
24.
a few words as usual on the main
EU economies
in Germany the economy is progressively
recovering after the energy price shock
of last year
a rebound in industrial production and
construction took place in the first
quarter but domestic demand remains
sluggish
GDP is forecast to grow by a subdued 0.2
percent in 23
led by net exports before accelerating
to 1.4 growth next year led by
investment and especially consumption
in France growth is projected at 0.7
percent investment is set to slow down
on the back of title Financial condition
wine consumption is expected to remain
sluggish this year the economy will gain
momentum in 24 reaching 1.4 growth tanks
mainly to higher consumption
in Italy real GDP growth is forecast at
1.2 percent in 23
economic activity remains supported by
Investments while net exports contribute
positively to growth
GDP is expected to expand at a similar
rate next year by 1.1 percent thanks to
a recovering consumption while the
contribution for an Investments and
external demand slows down
in Spain economic activity which is
still recovering from the pandemic Islam
being respected to decelerate this year
as in all the other U countries but
the rate of expansion of 1.9 in 23
remains well above the EU average thanks
to the implementation of the RF
and a very strong labor market
the country's economy is set to expand
further by two percent in 24 driven by
consumption and investment
in Poland
growth is expected to slow Market live
this year and elevated inflation Titan
finance and condition and low consumer
and business confidence take their toll
on domestic demand
economic activity should recover next
year as inflationary pressure gradually
subsides and financing conditions
improve
overall real GDP growth is forecast too
slow to 0.7 percent this year before
rebinding to 2.7 percent in 24.
lastly I mentioned earlier that this
forecast for the first time covers also
the new candidate countries
let me mention Ukraine for Ukraine this
section gives an idea
of the immense shocked cause to the
economy by the war that also of the
tremendous resilience it has shown
after a drop of around 29 last year
the economy is projected to grow by 0.6
percent this year and four percent in
2024. of course these projections are
subjects to all the caveats
you would expect in the current wartime
situation that this is the forecast in
this situation as it is now
inflation
inflation continues to fall thanks to
rapidly declining Energy prices
the Euro area headline inflation fell
onto an average of eight percent in the
first quarter of 23 down from 10 percent
in the final quarter of last year
however
as you know core inflation remains
persistently High rising in March to an
all-time high of 7.5 percent in the Euro
area
according to the recent flash estimates
for April
it declined to 7.3 percent
corroborating our projection
that the peak in core inflation is
behind us
looking ahead headline inflation is set
to continue slowing
core inflation
is expected to slow more gradually as
precious from past cost shocks weighing
and financing conditions Titan however
it should remain elevated throughout the
forecast Horizon reflecting the strong
wage Outlook
so inflation the Euro era is still
projected to decline from the 8.4 which
was 2022 to 5.8 in 23 and 2.8 in 24.
on inflation with the intra EU
differences
are expected to remain very high this
year but to narrow next year
as core goods and services take over as
the main inflation drivers the wide
range of inflation projections
predominantly reflects differences in
the outlook for core inflation
this can be attributed to different
domestic conditions and particular wage
growth
inflation in Central and Eastern Europe
is still markedly higher compared to the
rest of the Union
for the most part this reflects domestic
drivers including higher grade wage
growth and of course exchange rate
movements
Public Finance the strong nominal GDP
growth and the reduced cost of the
pandemic related emergency measures
supported the further reduction of the
EU government deficit in 2022
to 3.4 percent
of GDP 3.6 in the euro
despite sizeable energy support measures
still in place
in 23
and especially in 24 the gradual phasing
out of energy support measures is
expected to drive further deficit
reduction on aggregate in the EU
to 3.1 and 2.4 of GDP
3.2 and 2.4 in the Euro area
the debt to GDP ratio fell to 85 percent
of GDP in 22. from the record high of 92
percent in 2020 after the pandemic
during the pandemic
this debt to GDP ratio also is projected
to decline further
to below 83 percent of GDP in 24.
but to remain above the pre-covet level
of around 79 percent this was the 2019
figure
in the Euro area
depth to GDP is higher
that peaked at 99 percent of GDP in 2020
and it is projected to dip just below 90
percent by 24.
while inflation can support the
Improvement in public finances in the
short term
this effect is bound to dissipate over
time as that repayment cost increase and
public expenditures are progressively
adjusted to the higher price level
on the budgetary Outlook
several member states are still
projected in 23 to see a deterioration
in their General government balance
while falling Energy prices are helping
to contain the cost of existing support
measures many governments have
introduced new measures or are extending
existing
support energy support measures
in 2024
the deficit reduction is broad-based
across countries driven by the almost
complete phasing out of energy support
measures currently projected for next
year
so the number of countries with the
deficit exceeding three percent of GDP
is set to increase from 11 in 2022
to 14 this year before falling again to
10 member states in 2024 based of course
on unchanged policies
the balance of risks the balances risks
while the the Baseline projections
for the EU economy has slightly improved
since our Winter forecast
downside risks have increased
to a better Outlook but a
balance of risk
tilting to the downside
why because core price pressures could
turn out more persistent if wages
accelerate more than currently projected
and without adjustment in profit margins
this is one risk higher than expected
core inflation another risk would lead
to a stronger reaction of monetary
policy with broad microeconomic
ramification for investment and
consumptions
risks related to the EU external
environment will remain elevated new
uncertainties following the banking
sector turbulence or related to wider
geopolitical tensions
Rising interest rates on valuable
Emerging Markets
and of course Russia's war of
aggressions against Ukraine
continues to cast a long shadow of
uncertainty over the economy this is not
only
a human and geopolitical problem it is
also and broadly an economic big
risk
on the positive side
of of the balance more benign
developments in Energy prices or a
faster transmission of wholesale Energy
prices declines to Consumers would lead
to a faster decline in headline
inflation with positive spillovers on
domestic demands
in conclusion let me highlight
all right
a few takeaways from today's spring
forecast
uh first first I think we should be
proud of the fact that the European
economy is showing such remarkable
resilience
this is no small achievement given the
nature and the magnitude of the shocks
experienced
management of the energy crisis
coordination of fiscal policies
and impact of the RF all of these have
contributed to a much better than
expected scenario if we look back to
what we were expecting
last Autumn the scenario is more much
much
better second
this is no reason for complacency as we
always say inflation remains High
this means we must ensure that fiscal
policy is consistent with our policy
priorities
and in the same vein it is important to
maintain the momentum for growth in the
implementation of the recovery and
resilience plans
third take away the forecast illustrate
the remarkable country differences
concerning Public Finance but also
growth and inflation
it is important to monitor these
Divergence
to avoid that they become entrenched
and finally
our forecast vindicates the more
country-specific approach to fiscal
surveillance that is at the center of
our proposed reforms to the EU fiscal
rules
this is a further incentive to reach
agreement on this reform by the end of
the year
thank you and I'm looking forward for
your questions
please raise your hand
introduce out in the media you're
working
thank you David
I will ask my question in Italian if if
I may
recovery and resilient facility what is
the contribution of the recovery of
resilience
theoretical absorption so what I'm
asking is
how important
moving forward for the growth estimates
that you've indicated
that's one thing
would you say
Italiano
um
the contribution
in Italian
foreign
[Music]
an instrument like the RF is
extraordinary
extraordinary contributions foreign
and certainly yeah
foreign
and we will see for next year I'll take
your question and then I'll move to the
interactional platform
now this morning president thunderline
just had a speech in Parliament saying
that the conventional economic model we
have now is is not is not applicable
anymore we we cannot go on like this now
if the commission were to take that
seriously I would expect at the economic
growth uh forecast session like this one
we that we talk about uh resource
consumption that we talk about emissions
and and other stuff now this still feels
like a very conventional economic growth
uh forecast session so uh yeah why is
that another any plans to to change that
well this is a very good question
um
and
it was interesting uh two or three days
ago we had in
in nigata Japan
a an interesting conversation with Joe
stiglitz
you may imagine the subject of the
conversation which was the the effort
that stiglius is
doing uh on the label Beyond GDP effort
um
I think here we we are working
we have we are considering in our
recommendations in our policies
with a stronger role not only the
environmental Dimension but the social
dimension
um
we should gradually include more and
more the sustainable and development
goals
and I think you will perceive this more
and more in our what we call semester
packages the country specific
recommendations to member states so we
are fully aware of the needs of
improving
this we encourage green budgeting to
member states
but then you're right at the end of the
day at the end of the story when we look
to the IMF
uh the oacd European Union
um forecasting and Outlook
most of the attention is on the
internationally recognized
indicators
that we presented this morning so this
is a work in progress I think we have to
improve it and this doesn't mean that
GDP will disappear that this means that
in our fiscal policies and
recommendation we should
more and more and we will do and we are
doing it
include the different dimension of
economic well-being
Maria is joining us via the interaction
platform
good morning thank you for the floor
with the FC newspaper Greece I have one
and a half percent on Greece the Outlook
focus is generally positive the
commissioner but the problem activity
will slow down in 2023 and further
moderate in 24 is that a concern for the
economy and the half question is invest
in grade likely this year thank you
uh well
we
honestly everything can always be better
for everyone
but in the case of Greece it is clear
that we revised
substantially upwards our forecast
I've seen an important newspapers in
these days
stressing the good performance of the
Greek economy
so overall I think that the the result
are very very positive we have a uh 2.4
projection of for growth this year which
is the double of the Euro area average
and of course the the
we will see the evolution next year
but it's difficult for me to
to underscore negative elements because
we have a lot of positive elements
but of course
no complacency
closely monitored blah blah blah
to Ana Matos who's joining us online
Anna you have before
hi can you hear me yes we can hear you
yeah you can cannot see me right
no no okay and that was my question
anyway I thank you so much for the floor
um commissioner I have a couple of
questions on Portugal I wonder how
concerned this ever been commission
about the housing market in Portugal it
needs influence on the financial
stability and how does the European
commission monitor the performance of
the recovery and resilience plan given
that some delays in the implementation
have been known and I wonder also if I
may if Portugal already submitted a
rescheduling of its plan of irf thank
you so much
uh well thank you overall
we see
a positive forecast for for Portugal
have you as you have seen
um and
growth is
again
2.4 which is again double then you
average for this year so
we can't describe this as a negative
interesting to note also that the the
budget balance
of GDP despite a
a certain number of
significant energy related measures that
had a substantial impact on the on the
budget
but overall the the budgetary balance is
well better than other members that's
right I reminded before that we have
we will have this year more or less 14
member states in our forecast over the
famous three percent and this is not
this is not the case for uh for Portugal
um so we are cooperating with the the
Portuguese Authority on RF
I don't see we have technical delays
in the implementation with many
countries but I don't see
specific
problems both for that sustainability
and for the implementation of the area
submitted a revised plan just yet
then pass the floor through here
I would like to know if you if you have
taken into account that drove and the
dry periods and the lack of rain falls
in countries like Spain Italy or France
and if you consider this throw a threat
in terms of
inflation in certain sectors in a short
or medium periods of times thank you
of course the the
impact
of drought was very
important in several countries
and Spain is
among these
countries but I think it's interesting
also to note that the
energy
mix
of the Spanish situation was overall a
positive one
we can discuss on the extension of what
is called the Iberian model
but for sure the contribution
for
Spain was
overall positive
as you may have seen we
our projection for growth
quite encouraging for Spain
uh
despite the fact that we have slightly
different uh forecasts in relation to
um the the budget balance from the
Spanish authorities we have good
projection for growth
you have the floor
and a freshness I see Portugal you're
mentioning for Portugal these are a good
forecast nevertheless we also see in the
document and you are
um pointing to the declining in
purchasing power of households also
higher interest rates which is a big
problem for the families in Portugal
nowadays also you were mentioning
earlier that financing conditions are
set to tighten further so isn't this a
contradiction is it until missing the
social Dimension the dimension that you
were mentioning earlier and also in the
document UI pointing to these wage
adjustments that are expected to keep
pressure on prices and inflation what
exactly are you
recommending thank you
uh well indeed
there is a contradiction that the
contradiction is in the reality so we
have
for sure
from one side
loss of purchasing power
[Music]
the
results of increased
increase of wages
is projected to be stronger next year
but this year for sure is not
uh in itself
keeping the purchasing power
in in relation to inflation
so of course there is this
social aspect that you have to take into
account but at the same time you have to
try to avoid
a a price wage spiral
so how to deal with this contradiction
well first I think we
that
take note of the fact that in several
countries you have also
measures taken to
support
households in relation to the increasing
living costs
and these measure
were taken also in Portugal for example
income support for rents
vat exemption for selected goods
and increase in the remuneration
and pensions for civil servants
so we take note of this kind of measures
they have to we have also to consider
the fact that
in especially in some sector where
pentap demand was more strong
we have
margins and buffers in substantial
profits
to caution
the impact of
wage increase without
bringing this wage increase to influence
too much the rise of inflation so there
is a margin
and this margin is of course
probably declining in the next years but
nowadays it is there and it is
particularly there in some sectors where
the recovery from pentap demand is more
clear and this was is very clear both in
our analysis and in the ECB analysis
that you may have seen